bonjour pierre barbizet est là avec
françois et casimir et il va nous faire
découvrir des musiciens formidables qui
sait les grands romantiques la musique
comme vous les connaissez qu'est ce qu'a
écrit tristesse tu sais bien là dit tout
et de rire allez vincent
[Musique]
or
sur pas
[Musique]
oh
c'est beaucoup plus long que ça ça c'est
les sas et au 20e siècle on a dit que
c'était drissa faisait pleurer alors on
appelait sa tristesse de l'ami des
paroles dessus mais jamais chopin a
pensé à lui la place à une étude parce
que c'est beaucoup plus drôle c'est très
difficile
alors ben oui mais les états d'âme de
chopin était tout simple pour lui c'est
comme schumann c'est comme schubert ses
joueurs
à
attention ça lui plaît
[Musique]
très bon merci monsieur très beau alors
qu'est ce qui rime avec schubert
schumann alors sumann sous van vous
savez qu'il a écrit la musique avec goût
les enfants lui aussi alors il a écrit
beaucoup de musique de rêve et des îles
aété vrais malades et les morts fou et
toute sa vie il ya eu un peu des
hallucinations
le site est un grand poète il a écrit
mardi la liquidation
[Musique]
on
et
[Musique]
j'étais là c'est cheval toujours vivant
toujours et très imagé très romantique
oi oi oi oi